welcome to this video playing swap yeah
that's a frequent opponent right grandma
no international master Miller he does
not have the IM title in the in the name
yeah he's playing the Queens gambit all
the time some solid stuff huh what can I
do here I could I could try this
aggressive movie form but i don't really
know it check this is what Colin did
that I last year this how did he play
that it was quite ok what he had no I
don't remember I don't really feel like
sacrificing with Bishop b2 I don't know
that line at all it's been a long while
since I played it with with black
sometimes ok come here this pin on c3 is
a kind of uncomfortable something like
we need 5 m well don't like it very much
or night inform those early active moves
and maybe come on let's let's grab him
and try to force her the Queen trade I
mean at least I'm getting upon him he
will get it back pretty easily but I
really don't like this night you for
business all the time check yeah i was
thinking of this as possible but i
wasn't sure how good it is if i go Queen
to d3 I can cover all of it or Quincy
tune I can still play 94 now ok let's do
this Queen d3 really walks into e5 very
much
night chief
I just keep the keep the pressure gun to
see one now would have been much more
logical yeah I'm porn up but it's a
great porn right one of those great
triple pawns I really I don't think I
mean in terribly bad shape here just
just very ugly I get some time like
castles 94 I'm just having a pawn that I
can try to convert I mean this c5 phone
especially as covering an important
square only six but it is really an ugly
structure
yeah Queen d2 was really cilia if I do
this I should go Quincy one immediately
this position with the tempo up with
already having castle this is really
quite okay yeah that's a typical way to
play giving up this pawn to get
developed this is one one virtue of this
c5 pawn it term limits blacks
development options for the for the
light squared Bishop okay I thought 94
here maybe to clarify matters now in 93
a half knight c6 by the way so this is
this is so quite annoying actually yeah
I can take here 96 and then he's going
where Queen edged forward I still have
aged three okay
or bishop f1 what is better here Bishop
f4 maybe age three tags and maybe this I
don't know I shouldn't be thinking about
it so long the rook does not have super
great square has to go to but one
problem is that my c4 porn is really
hanging
I'd say Luke g7 yeah I can go h3 and 95
let's let's do that trying to keep
trying to keep c4 and maybe I can do
something with a queen trap like King h2
or threatening to trap the queen but you
can go to f5 okay but now here and then
G for his Queen a song was strapped
where do you go to tweenage for Bishop
g5 and that's it
hmm let's recently I'm cleanest Raptor
yeah I weird game and not a good one
probably yeah I don't know the theory
here and I don't like the position very
much maybe this xe5 was a bad idea I
don't know it's a it's always a very
debatable decision this I still think is
okay t I should go to see one really
this is this is really silly i'm losing
losing all this time I don't know maybe
black I mean black can also play like
this this is also not not a bad way to
develop let's say just just do something
like that and get the bishop our gym I
mean this is really really weak I have
some ideas you know I can try on the B
file and maybe I can get an ID to e46
but I mean black a certainty okay here
at least okay yeah this I don't know I
mean at this number i've got a pawn him
I am Bishop f4 was interesting here ok
and here look he made and I went to age
three and now Quincy five was good hmm
ok just attacking here I'm still not
still worse here according to the
computer yeah of course it was it was a
bit luckier this is Queen trap yeah this
is now lost 94 aslam is surreal the real
issue he should play this according to
the comp i was still intending to play
Queen III but maybe he can really just
take because of this resource this is
definitely not that great yeah that was
a somewhat somewhat weird game lucky for
me that he blundered the Queen basically
okay thanks for watching